KARISHMA SHAH:
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome.
Truly, welcome.
Thank you for joining us today.
You just saw the video
from last year's summit.
And I can feel the energy
in this room already.
It's going to be
equally amazing.
Let's connect,
create, collaborate,
and celebrate today.
If you can't already tell, I'm
excited to be here with you
and honored to support Women
Techmakers, a group that I hold
very near and dear to my heart.
And I'll tell you
why in just a bit.
Women Techmakers'
global vision is
to provide visibility,
community, and resources
for women in technology.
This is our third year hosting
our global event series
in celebration of
International Women's Day.
And this year I'm
personally looking forward
to the women in this
room exchanging stories
and inspiring each other.
I was the first female
on Project Wing,
X's drone delivery project.
One book that's
inspired me to embrace
such roles as a woman on teams
was written by Elle Luna.
And it's called "The
Crossroads of Should and Must."
What really resonated with me
was her stance that changing
our internal dialogue to
instill that we must be here,
rather than saying or
questioning whether we should
be here, has profound effects.
So today I'd like to say not
only should you all be here,
but the technology
industry needs
the insights, perspectives,
and ideas of females.
And you all must be here.
To quote Elle,
"must is who we are.
It's our super powers--
our truest, deepest,
most unique gifts deep
within us that we're allowing
to come forth and shine."
Must versus should
fosters the kind of work
that will put ripples
through the universe.
And I know the women inside
and outside of this room
are going to make waves in
the technology industry.
I truly believe that
diversity of thought
is the number-one
driver of innovation.
If we're going to solve the
challenges that face our world,
we need the cross
pollination of everyone's
curiosity, creativity,
and energy in the mix.
So today, let's honor who we
are and why we must be here.
I hope you'll be inspired
by the lineup of speakers,
organizations,
instructors, and workshops
put together by the fabulous
Women Techmakers team.
And before we kick off,
let's take a moment
to give it up for Women
Techmakers and women
in technology.
[APPLAUSE]
So Google is a place
where differences
are valued and encouraged.
I've experienced
this first hand.
A diversity of
perspectives and ideas
whether by gender, race, sexual
orientation, neurodiversity
or a combination of them all
lead to better decision making,
more creativity, better
products, and a greater value
to the workplace
and our culture.
We want to help the entire
tech industry become
more inclusive from
inspiring young students
to pursue computer
science degrees
to getting more minority-owned
small businesses online.
We want to create
an industry where
people can pursue their dreams,
build impactful technology,
and become leaders.
Woman Techmakers is
Google's global program
for women in technology.
It was kicked off in 2012 by the
current CTO of the White House
and then VP of X Megan Smith.
I'm going to take a
bit of time to talk
about Megan because it's
rare that I get this chance.
You know, I started out
as an intern in 2011
working for Megan.
And she's been my personal
sponsor, role model, and friend
since.
Without having crossed
paths with her,
I probably would
not be here today.
What I respect and
admire most about her
is she's a true believer that
no one is inferior or superior
to anyone.
She's instilled the
belief in me that ideas
can come from anywhere.
And when you find your
passion, you're unstoppable.
You can make amazing
things happen.
She believed in me, and
I'm eternally thankful.
And she believed in my very
dear friend, Natalie Villalobos.
Megan and I were interviewing
Natalie, actually,
about two and 1/2 years ago for
another role here at Google.
And, of course, Natalie
was my top choice.
And to my surprise and
disappointment at the time,
Megan came to me one day and
said, we're not hiring Natalie.
I have another plan for her.
And I said, come again?
Natalie and I led the 10x
Thinking team here at Google.
And fast forward,
here we are today.
Woman Techmakers is now led
globally by Natalie Villalobos.
She's my go-to person when
I need someone to "yes,
and" my ridiculous ideas.
And it's been amazing seeing
the evolution of her vision
from a concept we were
sketching on napkins
to the global scale
it's at today.
If you haven't met
her, I know she's going
to kill me for saying this.
But she's around, and
you ought to meet her.
She's a gem.
She and her global
team of Googlers
are passionate about
empowering women in technology
through increased visibility,
community, and resources.
At all of our events
this year, we're
celebrating the
theme of Our Time
to Lead, which was
created by the Anita Borg
Institute for last year's
Grace Hopper Conference.
By a show of hands, who was
at Grace Hopper last year?
OK, a good amount.
We've got to get
more of you there.
Together with the
Anita Borg Institute,
we're able to
increase the momentum
of this incredible movement.
Today, our goal is
to showcase women
at all phases of their
career as well as
organizations that are making
positive change in the tech
industry.
It's not just about Google.
A lot of times when we think
about diversity in technology,
we only think about
the United States.
But look at this map.
Women across the world
are coming together
to increase the visibility,
community, and resources
to enable more women
in the industry.
That's why across
March and April,
Women Techmakers will be
hosting 14 global summits
and over 100 community meet ups.
We believe in
supporting communities
wherever they are globally.
Our first summit
in Lagos, Nigeria
is actually happening
on March 19.
And today there are three
summits taking place
as we speak in Seattle, New
York, and, of course, here.
It's encouraging and empowering
to see so many women here
today.
Now, there are
hundreds of Googlers
helping out across all of our
summits and meet ups this year.
And a lot of times these folks
rarely receive a thank you.
And it's held till the
end, if it ever is done.
This year, let's
thank them first.
Their countless
hours and late nights
are what make days
like this possible.
Can the volunteers
please stand up
so we can give you
round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
If you ever need something
throughout today,
find one of them in a
Woman Techmakers shirt,
and they'll be sure to help you.
Today, we have an exciting
agenda in store for you.
I'm confident that, by
hearing the amazing talks
from our speakers today and
by informally networking
with each other, you will
end the day even more
ready to face challenges
and celebrate your triumphs.